[Música]
a
bueno yo lo primero que voy a ofrecer es
wifi gratuito a toda la sala teneis wifi
gratis todos podéis acceder comunicarnos
con vuestro pareja amante amigos
conectar con el banco hacer
transferencias es libre usando para lo
que queráis wifi gratis
bien y para comenzar me gustaría contar
la historia de mi amigo paco mi amigo
paco es un pirata un pirata que comenzó
allá por los años 80 y poco y pako en
los años 80 y poco tenía una técnica
peculiar para bajarse música que era
llamada por teléfono a la radio y pedir
una canción y rápidamente cuando la
ponían pulsamos rec en el radiocasete
para que para bajarse música y se bajaba
un disco en 9 10 12 días quizá algo
lento bien pago con el tiempo y estado
fibra en casa un gigabyte y claro pago
pasó de bajarse un disco en 12 días a
bajarse una discografía en dos segundos
paco tiene diógenes digital ha comenzado
a tener una cantidad de volumen de
información muchos y muchos y muchos
datos y almacenar tal cantidad de datos
que a veces le cuelan información falsa
datos
falsos datos que no corresponden a lo
que está bajando por ejemplo música o
películas mira sin ir más lejos el otro
día paco se bajó una película de
superman
tan falsa tan falsa que superman llevaba
calzoncillos por dentro aquí lo tenemos
aquí lo tenemos
bueno que cree eléctrico en ello que es
muy importante mantener la información
correctamente y ordenada de hecho hay
una cantidad de información gigantesca
que están fluyendo cada segundo cada
minuto de hecho en este último minuto se
han logrado más de dos millones de
personas a facebook se han visto
millones de vídeos en youtube es muy
importante
perdón que no pasa
es muy importante tener la información
siempre pura y al día el 90% de la
información que tenemos en estos
momentos en el planeta se ha generado se
ha archivado
estos últimos 2 años y esto parece mucho
se parece mucho pero en los últimos años
la tendencia va en crescendo
es decir crecemos con la capacidad de
cálculo de un 58 por ciento anual
brutal verdad
es muy importante filtrar la información
conseguir saber cuál es la información
buena de la mala saber dónde nos
conectamos saber qué dato podemos dar y
cuál no por qué porque podemos
encontrarnos con circunstancias como el
lado oscuro que es el lado oscuro pues
el lado oscuro es encontrar en la gente
quizá como yo o no que pueda utilizar
más la información como de mal
pues vamos a ver cómo de mal toda la
información circula a través de la
autopista de la información la autopista
de información tiene peajes peajes y
quien cobra esos peajes quizá los cobra
yo como cobra esos peajes con los datos
como los cobros pues bueno toda la gente
que os habéis conectado a mi wifi me
habéis dado usuario contraseña acceso sé
con quién hablar miedo verdad tranquilos
porque puedo hacer que vuestra página
web del banco que no sea la página web
del banco sea mi página web y me deis la
información a mí asusta pero se puede
complicar más todavía
puedo ser yo que no tengo bastante
dinero para transferir en vuestras
cuentas me parece poco me sale a poco
pues encriptar vuestra información
ponerle 2000 caracteres de clave para
que no lo encontráis nunca y pedir un
rescate digital pagarme tanto dinero
para recuperar esa información que a
priori es vuestra
bien
imaginemos que habéis sido avispas y no
habéis conectado la wifi pero me habéis
dejado un equipo cerca bien pues tengo
un pendrive que simplemente colocándolo
me transfiere toda la información que a
mí me interese por ejemplo claves o
historial de navegación
bien si eso se me queda corto hay esta
herramienta que simplemente colocándola
hace explotar el ordenador pues el
ordenador pues el sistema eléctrico del
coche cualquier sistema está a la venta
vale muy poquitos euros y hace explotar
los equipos asusta el pues esto no es
nada
y qué hago yo con esos datos para qué
valen esos datos esos datos que todos me
regala jce pues podemos saber la web
puede comenzar a traficar con ellos
vender número de tarjeta de crédito
bien de momento hemos visto dos maneras
de acceder la información por la wifi o
porque tengo acceso al equipo pero qué
pasaría si yo no tuviera acceso el
equipo no tuviera acceso a ningún medio
físicamente podría hacer algún daño a la
gente que está en la sala
y lo intentamos vamos a hacer que parte
de la gente que está en la sala llame
por teléfono a otra parte de la gente
que está en la sala
aquí es divertido y vamos a decir me
encanta este ponente me encanta este
tema
estáis comenzando a recibir llamadas
parte de la sala asusta es bueno
yo os voy a pedir un favor un último
favor que es que cuando terminemos
cuando lo hagáis por la puerta hay un
formulario por favor rellenando la
información vuestros datos yo ya sabría
qué hacer con ellos no os preocupéis
muchas gracias y gracias por vuestros
datos
[Aplausos]